[Music]
am i dead
already i must be i mean this is a
punishment right
yep this is death
this isn't happening i'm going to have
to make an emergency landing
[Music]
no no you
i can't stand it you are
breathe no you don't get to tell me what
to do
you don't get to tell me anything we're
are you even listening i count three
anti-aircraft cannons
three what you'll be safe here oh
i'll be safe safe
i haven't been safe since i found you i
found you remember
you were out there on your own and you'd
still be out if it wasn't for me
i thought i was going home there won't
be a home if we don't stop the banished
you keep saying that we're outgoing
outnumbered
i know i saw clone wars over there i'm
going to dig through them and find one
with the working sleep space drive
and when you're done with this war we'll
get away from here
far away wait here
oh please
let me see what i can find canon's first
when i get back we can look
together
[Music]
okay be good
uh
uh
um
[Music]
[Music]
i'm turning around
mm-hmm
now
this system
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[ __ ]
hey
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
oh
the uranus lost this war
months ago your people
are broken scattered
haunted defeated
by me i wish i could tell you it was
difficult
but it wasn't
we are one step ahead always
the ring is already under our control
soon the auditorium is well
share the same goal we fight
together to honor the will of atriox
without challenge i grew
weary lost
alone
here you now stand
this is my last
fight true test
of legends our story
will outlive us both
[Music]
set a fire in your heart spartan
bear your fans
fight hard i
will
[Music]
[Music]
you